kristen sinani is an associate professor
at stanford university she teaches
statistics and writing
works on statistical projects in sports
medicine and writes about health
science and statistics for a range of
audiences
she authored the health column body news
for allure magazine for over a decade
she is also the statistical editor for
the journal physical medicine and
rehabilitation
and she authors a statistics column
statistically speaking
for this journal she teaches the popular
massive
open online course writing in the
sciences on coursera
and she was the recipient of the 2018
biosciences award
for excellence in graduate teaching at
stanford university
thanks jackie so today i'm going to
teach a few statistic lessons
using examples from the news and i'm
going to present three case studies for
you that illustrate different
statistical principles and i'm going to
start here
by talking about how we quantify and
describe risk
using a recent example related to kobit
19.
in just a second here i'm going to play
a short video clip and this is from a
white house press conference
and the speaker is the fda commissioner
stephen hahn
19 convalescent plasma is safe
ensures promising efficacy thereby
meeting the criteria for an emergency
use authorization
in the optimal treatment of the optimal
patients as described by secretary azar
treated with convalescent plasma at the
highest titers
there was a 35 percent improvement in
survival
which is a significant clinical benefit
now we're waiting for more data
we're going to continue to gather data
but this clearly meets the criteria that
we've established for
emergency use authorization and we're
very pleased with these results so let
me just put this in perspective many of
you know i was a cancer doctor before i
became fda commissioner and a 35 percent
improvement
in survival is a pretty substantial
clinical benefit
what that means is in in if the data
continue to pan out
100 people who are sick with covet 19
35 would have been saved because of the
administration of plasma
we've seen a great deal of demand for
this from doctors around the country
and what this eua does the eua emergency
use authorization today does
it allows us to continue that
okay so you heard uh the fda
commissioner there make two quantitative
statements he said that in patients
treated with convalescent plasma at the
highest antibody titers
there was a 35 improvement in survival
and then he translates that he says what
that means is
that if you have a hundred people sick
with copin 19 you could save
35 of them by the administration of
plasma
um he's made an error there actually and
in fact uh right after the white house
press conference statistics twitter just
kind of lit up
pointing out his error i'm going to walk
you through the error because
it illustrates a larger statistical
principle
so where did that 35 statistic come from
it came from a study that was published
as a preprint
uh back in august and this was an
observational study of coca-19 patients
all of whom were treated with
convalescent plasma
so convalescent plasma is when you take
blood from people who have survived
covet
and you give it to people who are stick
with kovid the idea being that you might
be giving them antibodies against code
there was no control group um but
the reason they measured the levels of
antibodies in the blood samples that the
patients received
and found that in fact um
some people had gotten blood with very
high levels of antibodies
and some people had gotten blood with
much lower levels of antibodies so they
used that low antibody group
essentially the outcome was seven day
mortality whether or not you died within
seven days of receiving
the treatment and they compared the high
antibody group to the low antibodies
group and they got a risk ratio
of 0.65 indicating a reduction
in deaths um in those who got the high
antibody plasma versus those who got
the low antibody plasma
so let's actually now uh just uh dig
into the numbers that they used
uh to calculate that risk ratio so here
i'm showing you the data for seven day
mortality
by group high medium or low antibodies
items
what the authors did is they calculated
what we call a
relative risk or a risk ratio so they
divided the risk of death in the high
antibody group
by the risk of death in the low antibody
group 8.9 percent
divided by 13.7 that gives a risk ratio
of 0.65
this was in fact marginally
statistically significant at the 0.05
level
but how would you translate that in
words well you could say that in
relative terms
this is a 35 improvement in survival
so in fact the fda commissioner got that
first statement correct
but there's another way that you can
present the numbers here so instead of
calculating the
relative risk you can calculate what we
call the absolute risk difference
and um this is where instead of dividing
the risk
you're going to subtract that so 13.7
percent of the patients in the low
antibody
group died within seven days versus
eight point nine percent of the patients
in the high antibody group
that is an absolute reduction in deaths
of
4.8 or you could say there were 4.8
or about five fewer deaths per
100 coded patients now notice that's
different
than what the fda commissioner said
so the fda commissioner actually made an
error here he said there were
you would save 35 people out of 100 when
it's actually five
uh the error that he made is that he
mistakenly
interpreted a relative risk as if
it was an absolute risk um this just
goes to show you that quantitative
communication
is hard even people with lots and lots
of training
can mess this up when they go to
translate math
into words um all right so now i'm going
to tell you a little bit more
in general about the concepts of
absolute versus relative
uh risk
and i think it actually helps to make an
analogy here so
i'm teaching my kids about you know
fractions and decimals and they always
find it easier if i put it in money
terms so i'm going to make an analogy
here and imagine
my daughter wants to buy a stuffed
animal um this cute little stuffed blob
fish here
and it normally costs 13.70 but it's now
on sale for 8.90
so you can ask the question how much is
she saving
and there's two ways to answer that
question you can talk about the absolute
amount to saving 4.80
or with money we often talk
in relative terms so you can also talk
about the relative amount here
890 is 65 of 13.70
so she is saving 35
or she's getting 35 off off now
the relative information is really never
enough information it doesn't give the
whole picture right because
if you have 35 off of an item that costs
a thousand dollars
that's a 350 savings but if you have 35
off an item that costs one dollar that's
just a 35
savings so it's important in addition to
having the relative amount
to also always have information about
the absolute amount
students find it tricky uh to
communicate relative risks in words so
i'm going to go over a few examples now
so for example if you have a risk ratio
of 0.5
that is a halving of risk or you could
say a 50
decrease in risk if you have a risk
ratio of two
that is a 100 increase in risk and this
always confuses students they want to
say that it's a 200 increase in this
but again it helps to make an analogy to
money so imagine you have an item that
costs ten dollars and it
increases in price to twenty dollars
that is a ten dollar increase
which is a one hundred percent increase
in price not a two hundred percent
increase in price
um similarly a risk ratio of 2.5 that is
a 150 percent increase in risk
not a 250 increase in risk
and as i already alluded to
the whole story it's important to always
give information about outside risks as
well and you know i have to give the fda
commissioner credit for he was he was
trying
to give information about absolute risk
he messed up the numbers but at least he
was trying to give that complimentary
information
um and that's because you can see here
if you've got an exposure that increases
your risk of disease
from 0.01 to 0.02
that is a risk ratio of two but you're
also getting a risk ratio of two if
you're increasing your risk from ten
percent to twenty percent
but those are very different cases right
in the first case
you're increasing your risk from one in
ten thousand to two in ten thousand that
is a one in ten thousand increase in
risk in absolute first
in the second case though you are
increasing your risk in absolute terms
by one in ten
those are very different even though
they have exactly the same
risk ratio
all right the second case study i'm
going to present here i want to teach
some concepts in probability
best presidential election as an example
so we now have to travel back in time
here to 2016
right before the us presidential
election in 2016.
and many of you may remember that right
before the election
a lot of election forecasters were very
confident that hillary clinton
was going to win the election the
washington post
said the 2016 election is already
decided
new york times gave her an 85 chance to
win
the huffington post had her at a 98
in fact they said trump has essentially
a new path to an electoral college
victory
538.com did a little better they put her
at a 70
chance to win so they did have a real
path you know for donald trump to win
but you know still a high probability
the princeton election consortium had
her at a 99
chance of a win and in fact the author
of that website sam wang
was so confident that she was going to
win that he said if she lost
he would eat a bug on live tv so he
actually had to eat a cricket on cnn
all right fast forward now to the year
uh we have a presidential election
coming up in just two weeks um i knew
the election is probably on a lot of
your minds it's certainly online i have
already voted
um but now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to present to you
an election prediction from 2020 that
makes some of the errors
that happened in the election forecast
in 2016.
so this election forecast comes from the
ms cannon center website it's not a
website i would normally traffic
but i happen to have found this example
on twitter and you can see that i get a
lot of my teaching examples from twitter
these days
um they put out a prediction in
mid-september
with a byte in chance of a win at 95
and you can see their uh the results of
their statistical
model over here on the right hand side
of your screen
and so what they are doing is they are
modeling the election in terms of
electoral college boots
for joe biden so that's what's on the
x-axis the y-axis is probability and so
the height of these
bars represents the probability of
different outcomes in the election in
terms of
electoral college votes for joe biden
now let me remind you how the american
election system works so each state
there are a few districts but primarily
each state
has a certain number of electoral
college votes whoever wins the state
wins those votes um there are 538 total
electoral votes
you need 270 to win and you can see
that all of these bars that are blue
that's where
biden got at least 270 and wins the
election there are only a very few cases
where uh biden gets less than 270 and uh
trump wins the election so this puts
biden at a very high chance of a win
again where i found this example is i
happen to follow nate silver on twitter
and he
is the founder of 538.com and he tweeted
about this particular election forecast
a few weeks ago
and he says i can't believe after 2016
that people are still modeling the
electoral college
as though each state is independent and
giving biden a 99.5
chance of victory state polling errors
are highly correlated this is bad math
and is misinforming people
um in fact uh a few days after this
tweet came up
out i went to the ms cannon center
website and i saw that they'd actually
pulled down
their election prediction so they listen
to him i guess
you can still find it in google archives
though if you want it as a teaching
example
um what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to walk you through
the error that nate silver is pointing
out here because it illustrates a larger
statistical point
all right i'm going to read through
their methodology now just quickly and
then i will illustrate it with pictures
so they say ultimately 16 states
uh were projected as swing states or
districts
so swing states uh means that the
outcome
is uncertain so their model is actually
only based on 16 states and this is
because
for most states in america we're pretty
sure
who's going to win that state so for
example
um we're pretty sure that california and
new york
are both going to go to joe biden in
fact if biden doesn't win california and
new york
that will mean that something crazy has
happened in the election
i am not putting it past 2020 but uh
let's just say that we can
hopefully safely put new york and
california in the binding column and so
what this model does is it says let's
you know assume that those states where
we're
pretty darn sure what's happening we're
just gonna put uh
the votes uh for biden that's 203 and
both
votes for trump that's 122. we're just
going to assume that those are safe
votes from non-swing states
we're only going to focus on the states
where things are uncertain
they then say therefore we can consider
that there are sixty five thousand five
hundred and thirty six or two raised to
the 16
different areas in which the electoral
map can potentially unfold
with some scenarios more likely others
so what they're saying here is every
state has two possible outcomes
five wins or trunk widths and there are
16 states
so that gives us two raised to the 16
different ways the electoral map can
unfold
each of these scenarios was evaluated
using what can be referred to as a
multiple coin toss technique
for example if you have two points the
probability of both of those coins
landing on heads is 50
times 50 or 25
you can then calculate the overall
chance of different scenarios by
multiplying probabilities and this
technique was used on a large scale
to calculate the probability and the
respective electoral college
outcome for each of the 65 000 scenarios
all right so now i'm going to illustrate
that with some pictures
so what the miss cannon center did is
they essentially flipped a weighted
coin for each of the swing states so for
example
pennsylvania is a swing state with 20
electoral college votes
current polling at least when i made
these slides i made this size maybe two
weeks ago so the polls may have slightly
changed but at that point
um the probability of abiding win was
somewhere around 80 the probability of a
trump win was around 20 percent
so the niskanen center flips a weighted
coin with an 80
chance of heads and a 20 chance of tails
if you get heads by their wins if you
get tails from wins
now where did that 80 probability come
from in fact in this canon center did
not publish the probabilities that they
used in their model
so what i did is i went to 538.com they
published probabilities for each state
so i just use their probabilities
where do those probabilities actually
come from well they come
primarily from the current polling data
i think 538.com may throw a few other
things in the soup to come up with those
probabilities there but they're
primarily determined by polling data
and so the pennsylvania polls for
example the time i made these slides had
biden up 5.1 ahead of trump
but that doesn't mean that by
that polls have error and so if you take
into the
account the fact that you know that
there's going to be some error there's
some chance that those pulls are off and
could be off by quite a bit
um that that gives you an 80 chance of a
buying
weight that's the idea the miss cannon
center then flips a weighted coin
for another swing state say florida
which has 29 electoral votes uh when i
made these slides 538.com had biden and
about 60
um now we have four possible outcomes in
the election right four branches to this
tree
but then we can do this again for a
third swing state ohio which has 18
electoral
college votes it's pulling a little
closer between biden and trump
now we have eight possible outcomes in
the election
uh and i'm going to stop at three states
and that's all that's going to fit on my
slide
if i did all 16 states my tree here
would have 65 000 branches i can't fit
that on the slide
and uh so i can get the idea with just
three states
so i'm going to stop at three states
just to give you the idea
all right so now we have eight possible
outcomes right
two raised to the third possible ways uh
these states can unfold
so biden for example could win all three
states
if he does he would get 67 electoral
votes
the discount center calculates the
probability of that particular outcome
by multiplying the probabilities of the
coin clips together so 0.8
times 0.6 times 0.53 gives you 25.4
percent chance of that outcome
he also binding could also win
pennsylvania and florida but lose ohio
he would get 49 electoral values and put
it at a probability of
eight times 10.47 which is 22.6
or fighting could win pennsylvania and
ohio but lose florida that would give
them 38 electoral votes
they put that at a 17 chance and so on
uh of course you know they have to do
this across 65 000 branches so we are
certainly not going to do this by hand
you're going to implement this
calculation in a computer
and so i wanted to recreate their method
so what i did is i
use what's called a computer simulation
to do this calculation in the computer
for me
all right so let me explain how a
computer simulation works um so what i'm
doing essentially
is i am running a large number of
virtual elections in the computer
and the idea here is i want to see how
frequently
different electoral college outcomes
occur and that will tell me
their probability how likely they are so
what i start doing is i first
run one virtual election in the computer
and to do this
i have the computer flip a virtual coin
for each swing state and that virtual
coin is weighted by the probability of a
biden win
so for example for pennsylvania i weight
the coin by 80 percent
uh i have the computer flip that coin
virtually if i get heads fine wins if i
get tails trump wins
and then i do this for all of the swing
states and i add up all the electoral
votes from those three states
i then add in the votes from the
non-swing states and i come up with an
election result
so i do this once but then i repeat this
a really large number of times and i did
this a million times in my computer
why a million it's totally arbitrary
that is just a really big number
that doesn't hang my computer so this
simulation will run in under a second in
my computer on my laptop
then i can look at how frequently do
different outcomes occur and that is
their probability
all right to make this a little bit more
concrete i'm now showing you just
uh the result of one of those virtual
elections from my simulation out of a
million
and i should say i used um 17 swing
states or districts in my model
the discount central team uh i use the
probabilities uh from 538.com i don't
know exactly what probabilities they use
so we may get slightly different results
but you'll see in a minute it's very
close
so what do i do well for example alaska
has three electoral votes
current polling has widened at about a
22 chance of a win
so i have the computer flip a virtual
coin with a 22
chance of heads and in this iteration of
my simulation in this virtual election
i get a tails and actually bite and
loses um i
then flip a virtual coin for arizona uh
the 64
chance of heads and in this case up
biden wins i get a heads
and i do this for all of the swing
states and then i add up the electoral
college
total from this particular iteration of
my simulation
100 i add that to the 203 that's you
know safely in his column
and i get that he gets 311 electoral
votes and wins the election
but then i do this a large number of
times i do this a million times
and i see um how it sorts out in all of
those million times and i'm going to
plot it in histogram so you can look at
that distribution
but i'm showing you here on the right
hand side of my screen that is the
histogram from my simulation and what
you'll notice is that it looks an
awful lot that's right and getting very
similar results in it
um i get slightly different results a
slightly lower probability of abiding
wind because
again i use slightly different
parameters in my model but i get a bell
curve shape
and i get a very high probability of a
vitamin um and you can see that most of
the time
in those simulations we got somewhere
between two you know fine got somewhere
between 270 and
you know 400 electoral bits so putting
him at a very high chance of a win
all right but as
uh nate silver already pointed out this
approach
has a problem so this multiple coin toss
technique that they use
relies on an assumption so in
probability we have this
that says that if you have two events
and you want to calculate the
probability of
both of those events occurring like when
i flip two coins i get two heads
that's what we call a joint probability
you can calculate that probability
by multiplying together the probability
of each individual event occurring
separately what we call
the marginal probability that is the
probability of getting a heads
on the first point off times the
probability of getting ahead
on the second point that works
if the two events in question are
independent
so of course coin flips are independent
right if i flip a coin and i get a heads
that doesn't change my probability of
getting a heads on the next pointless
but state to state results in an
election are absolutely not independent
they are highly correlated
so for example if trump wins michigan
this greatly increases the probability
that he is going to win
wisconsin and this is because polling
errors are correlated
so if the polls have underestimated a
michigan win for trump
they have almost certainly
underestimated a wisconsin win for him
and uh so what this means is we can't
simply multiply the probabilities of the
different states together
to get the overall probability if we do
that we're going to get the wrong answer
and this is some of what went wrong in
those election forecasts
in 2016.
so what i'm showing you here now is this
table is from a paper
that did a post-mortem of the 2016
election
forecast and the data in this table come
from the new york times data that were
published in the new york times the
night
before the 2016 presidential election
and so there are times the night before
the election had clinton
up two percentage points in florida
seven percentage points in michigan
one percentage point in north carolina
five in pennsylvania six in wisconsin
as it turns out trump actually won all
six of those states and you can see the
margins by which he won
in the slide here for example in florida
the pre-election polls had clinton up
two points
and trump won by 1.2 points
the pre-election polls had overestimated
a clean win in florida by
3.2 percentage points and you can see
that in fact in all six of these states
the polls overestimated for clinton and
they all overestimated by
very similar amounts this means that the
polling errors were not independent they
are highly correlated
yet very similar errors in all of the
states
whatever went wrong in the polls in
michigan also went wrong
in the polls in wisconsin and we can
speculate as to what might happened
you know maybe uh polster didn't reach
trump voters
maybe trump voters uh lied to pollsters
about their voting intentions maybe
trump voters were more likely to show up
on election day could be all
all of those things right but whatever
went wrong it was off
you know by similar amounts and in the
same direction across
all of these states so what happened in
a lot of the
2016 election forecasts in those models
is that they did not account for the
fact that
states might be correlated or if they
did account for it they inadequately
accounted for that correlation
so what i did next is i tweaked my
simulation
just a little bit to focus on the
polling data rather than the
probabilities of a biden win
and remember those probabilities came
directly
from the polling data so these are
really just two different ways of
looking at the same thing
and so you can see the results of my
simulation here it's basically the same
as before this doesn't really change
anything
but i'm just looking at it a slightly
different way and so what i'm doing now
though is instead of randomly flipping a
coin
for each state i'm instead randomly
generating a
polling error for each state and
uh i'm assuming that there is some kind
of like plausible distribution of
plausible
polling errors here so maybe the polling
errors could range
anywhere from negative twenty percent to
positive twenty percent
and negative twenty percent would mean
that they are underestimating for biden
by twenty percent
positive twenty percent would mean that
they are overestimating for biden by
twenty percent
and i'm gonna assume in my distribution
here that like
very large polling errors are less
likely than smaller pulling errors
but rather than flipping a coin now to
determine the outcome of each state what
i'm going to do instead is i'm going to
throw a virtual dart onto this dart
board which represents the distribution
of my polling errors here
and that uh polling error that comes up
that i randomly generate will actually
determine the outcome of that state
so for example when i need these slides
biden was pulling up 5.1 percent ahead
of trump in pennsylvania
but then in my simulation what i'm going
to do is have the community i'll throw
this virtual dart
come up with a polling error for
pennsylvania and in this iteration
i get that the polling error in
pennsylvania is a six percent
overestimate what does that mean well
that means that trump is going to win
the election
in pennsylvania by 0.9 and so i'm then
in that iteration of the simulation
gonna put pennsylvania
in trump's column and then of course i
do this for every swing state
um and that gives me an election outcome
and then i do this a million times as
before
and i should note that in my
distribution just as many negatives as
positives
so i am assuming that polling errors are
equally likely to help fight in return
here
this is still treating the states as
independent though so i am throwing a
random dart for each state separately
these polling errors are still
uncorrelated that's why i get basically
the same result as before
but this makes it easier this uh redo of
my simulation makes it easier for me
then to incorporate
correlated polling errors so that's what
i do next i changed my simulation
to make the polling errors in certain
states correlated
so for example i thought maybe michigan
wisconsin pennsylvania ohio north
carolina
florida and minnesota might be
correlated because they were correlated
in 2016. i gave them a correlation the
coefficient of 0.8 which is very high
i also thought maybe texas arizona and
nevada might go together so i gave them
um a high correlation i should
give a disclaimer here to say that um i
just made these correlation structures
up i
this is not based on any empirical data
so i am not trying to accurately
uh predict the election here i just want
to show you
the effect of adding correlation into
the model how that
changes the results so this is just
meant for illustration
yeah it's important to keep in mind now
that the polling errors are still
equally likely to help trump or biden so
my distribution
has just as many negatives as positive
just as many errors that help item adds
that help trump
so i am not building in any systematic
error for trump here
but the fact of adding correlation still
greatly changes
this model
so now here i'm showing you the results
of my
it's a lot different than before so i no
longer have a nice bell
uh shaped curve uh and the probability
of abide in wind drops precipitously
you know to 87.7 so just the fact of
adding correlation to this simulation
it actually helps the underdog here and
why is that
well if you think about it think about
when we were modeling
the states as independent coin flips or
independent dark roads
you had to have a lot of flukes in a row
occur
in order for trump to win right you had
to have a whole bunch of points that
were weighted towards heads
you know come up tails
so that creates very few paths to a
trump win
if you have correlated states that means
now you just kind of need one fluke
one odd coin flip or one odd dart throw
and that moves all of the states with
it and that now opens up many more paths
to a trump win
so just for comparison save now i'm
showing you the
uh election prediction from 538.com
again i made these slides a few weeks
ago so this was maybe from early october
if you look at the bottom panel there
they have modeled the election outcome
in terms of electoral
votes for for biden and you can see it
looks pretty similar
to the uh election prediction that i
just showed you
it's again this more spread out
distribution not bell-shaped
and similarly the economist has an
election prediction that kind of has a
similar shape more spread out not
bell-shaped
some paths to a trump win so both of
these models that i just showed you
are actually accounting for correlation
between states
all right the final case study that i
want to discuss today i want to
illustrate
the ideas of confounding and statistical
adjustment
and i'm going to use vitamin d as an
example
so you may have seen some headlines
recently related to vitamin d
there have been some studies claiming
that vitamin d can reduce your risk of
coronavities
um actually in the last two decades
there are have been
a lot of headlines about vitamin d
so uh there's been everything you know
tons of studies making plans about
vitamin d
there's been studies saying vitamin d
can prevent dementia
that it can prevent cancer that it can
fight depression
um in fact for almost any condition or
disease you can think of
i bet you there is a study out there
somewhere saying that vitamin d improves
that condition
um i happen to be though largely a
vitamin d skeptic
and that's because um i do think that
vitamin d
is important in bone health there's good
data to support that but the data for
everything else is a lot murkier and
that's because most of these vitamin d
studies
have been observational studies and
vitamin d has a problem it is a
highly confounded variable so um
people who have healthy habits people
who are healthy in general
they tend to have higher vitamin d
levels but that doesn't mean that the
vitamin d
causes them to be healthier it's maybe
just a marker of good health
and i'm now going to discuss my favorite
study to illustrate this particular
point
and this is a study that came out uh two
years ago it claimed that your vitamin d
levels could help improve your aerobic
fitness
and it got a lot of media attention it
had an old metric score of 320 which is
considered very high i'm showing you
some headlines here
if you look at the second news article
there it has a subheading and it says
the sunshine vitamin is important for
bone and brain health but new research
suggests it can also make the lungs and
heart more efficient as well
so they are actually making a causal
claim about vitamin d
fitness and if you read further
in that news article it says the study
notes that vitamin d
could potentially affect cardiovascular
in several ways
for starters the nutrient has been shown
to boost the production of muscle
protein
and aid in calcium and phosphorus
transport on a cellular level
it may also affect the body's makeup of
fast twitch muscle fibers
suggesting that vitamin d may improve
aerobic fitness the authors wrote
so they are clearly trying to make a
causal claim they're trying to explain
how at a biological level
vitamin d could actually directly boost
your aerobic fitness levels
um and it's funny because a lot of times
we blame journalists for over hyping
scientific results in the news i think
though
a lot of the times it's not really the
journalists it's actually the authors
who have over hyped the results in their
paper
a lot of times it's simply the
journalists parenting what the authors
have said and that's certainly
the case here
all right so what was the study the
study used
data from the national health and
nutrition survey in hayes
and this is a study that periodically
surveys a representative
sample to the health of the us
population the researchers here
specifically took data on young people
who had had both their vitamin d levels
and their vo2 max levels
measured through nhanes because they
wanted to look at the association
of those two variables all right i'm
showing you table one from the paper i'm
going to zoom in on this in a minute
uh but just keep in mind that the
researchers divided the participants
into quartiles
by their vitamin d levels all right
zooming in now
um as expected because
they formed these groups based on their
vitamin d levels the vitamin d levels
then of course
go up across the quartiles um uh because
these groups are formed based on vitamin
d so for example
the lowest quartile of vitamin d the
average vitamin d level was
35 nanomoles per liter in the highest
quartile of vitamin d
the average vitamin d was 83 nanomoles
per liter
they then looked to see do the vo2 max
levels
differ in these different different
vitamin d groups
and they did indeed find that the
average vo2 max
increases as you go up across the
vitamin d groups
and so for example if you look at
the first quartile compared to the
second lowest vitamin d group compared
to the second lowest vitamin d group
you see about a two unit increase in
vo2max i'm
rounding here but it's roughly 38 to 40.
if you go from the first quartile to the
third quartile it's roughly a three unit
increase in vo2 max
if you go from the first quartile to the
fourth quartile it's roughly a
four unit increase in do2 max i am
rounding very heavily here but i just
want to make
easy numbers to remember
but as i alluded to before vitamin d
is related to a lot of other variables
and you can see this if you look through
the rest of table 1.
so for example we know that obesity is a
risk factor for low vitamin d
uh obesity impairs your ability to
absorb vitamin d and you can see that
here
the low vitamin d group had an average
bmi of 29.1
whereas the high vitamin d group was
much lower an average bmi of 25.9
vitamin d is also strongly related to
skin pigment and so the more pigment you
have in the skin
that blocks the absorption of vitamin d
and
sunlight is very important in the body
for the production of vitamin d
so not surprisingly the high vitamin d
group hit here had
many more white participants than the
low vitamin d
people with certain health problems also
tend to have lower vitamin d levels
and so for example these are young
people so there aren't that many people
in the sample with diabetes and
hypertension but if you look
there are more people and low vitamin d
groups in those conditions compared
with the high vitamin d groups
all right i'm now showing you the main
figure from this paper so let me orient
you to this figure event so first of all
on the x-axis we have vo2max
the upper panel these are the unadjusted
results the bottom panel that's the
adjusted results
and what the authors did is they
compared the
mean or average vo2 max in the
higher vitamin d groups compared with
the lowest vitamin d group so the
reference group here is that first
quartile or the lowest
vitamin d group the squares that you see
on the plot
those represent the difference in means
between the different quartiles compared
with quartile one so for example as we
already pointed out if you look at this
top panel here
if you compare quartile two to quartile
one quartile two is about
2 units higher in vo2max if you look
down the x-axis here
quartile 3 is about 3 units higher in
vo2max compared to the first quartile
and quartile 4 was about 4 units higher
as we already saw in table 1.
what they did is they fit a linear
regression model here so the outcome is
vo2max
the predictor is your vitamin d groups
the beta coefficients from that model
represent
the mean differences between those
groups so again quartile 2 compared to
quartile one the difference is about two
quartile three compared to quartile one
the difference is about three and the
fourth quartile
uh the difference from hotel one was
about four
that's before we take into account
confounders
what they did next though is they
adjusted their models for potential
confounders age
sex race bmi hypertension the variables
that they had available
in n-hanes and what you see is in the
adjusted models
there is a smaller effect size so the
differences in the means between the
groups gets closer to zero
you can see this in all of the groups
they the difference is shrink
the beta coefficients become smaller
they become closer to zero
and this is what you expect to see if
there is compounding once you account
for the confounding
the effect sizes get smaller
so there is confounding going on here
but what the authors did is that they
looked at these results and they said
well
um the difference between quartile 2 and
quartile 1 is no longer statistically
significant you can see that the
confidence interval now crosses 0 for
that group
but 4 channel 3 and quartile 4 remain
significantly higher than quartile 1
so they use this finding to argue that
therefore vitamin d
affects your vo2max levels
and they spun a whole causal story about
this right they came up with
physiological explanations how this is
working at the biological level
the journalists in the news article i
showed you earlier actually already did
a really good job of summarizing those
so i'm not going to read
those um but
there is an elephant in the room here
right there is a major confounder that
we have not accounted for here
um they were not able to account for
this confounder because they did not
have the variable available
to them in in aids
so if you think about what are the
things that are vitamin d levels
well the major one is your exposure to
sunlight
but if you then think about what are the
things that affect vo2 max
well the major one is your physical
activity level if you are more
physically active you're going to have
better aerobic fitness
but where does most physical activity
occur well it occurs outdoors
so people who are going outdoors to
exercise they are going to have
better vo2 max but guess what they're
also getting exposed to the sun so they
are also going to have
better vitamin d levels and i believe
that this
can probably explain the association
that we are seeing in this study
now the authors do mention this way down
at the bottom of the discussion
section they say the results were not
adjusted for vitamin d intake
diets or physical activity both of which
may have an effect on the observed
association
the problem is that that little sentence
buried down the bottom of the discussion
to me
that's the whole story the most
plausible explanation of the association
we're seeing here
is due to physical activity not because
you know vitamin d
somehow affects your phosphorus levels
and your fast muscles
physical activity is a more plausible
explanation for what we're seeing here
and this just gets the larger problem of
unmeasured and residual confounding so i
think a lot of the vitamin d
studies we're going to find out later
the observe the associations we were
seeing were really just due to
confounding
um and that's because studies again were
observational studies
and in when authors are presenting
observational studies they often say
things like well we adjusted for all
these confounders
and the implication is that you know
since you adjusted for them you don't
have to worry about them in
but this statistical adjustment is not a
panacea
just because uh you've done some
statistical adjustment doesn't mean
you've taken care of all compounding
for confounders we haven't measured like
physical activity in this particular
example
but it's important to also realize that
even when a compounder is
included in the model that doesn't mean
you have perfectly taken
care of it um there's always what we
call
residual or leftover compounding and
this occurs because
you can only perfectly mathematically
adjust the weight for something
if you have measured it and modeled it
perfectly
we rarely are able to do that with
confounders right i mean think about
physical activity
we often measure did you do a lot or a
little physical activity
well if we've measured it crudely we
cannot perfectly adjust for it which is
going to
create some leftover or residual
confounding
which can create spurious associations
all right i'm going to wrap up here to
leave some time for questions but i'll
just point out a few further resources
so i do teach the medical statistics
certificate program for stanford online
i'll say a few more words about that
program in a minute
i also write a column on statistics for
the journal
physical medicine and rehabilitation i
have a number of different
columns on different specific
statistical topics and i try to write
those in a reader friendly way
as to the certificate program this is a
three-course
program i do teach programming in either
sas or r
you are not required to have any
previous programming experience
med stats one covers things like
descriptive statistics and measures of
disease
risk and association kind of similar to
the code example i did today
medstats 2 covers probability inference
and simulation my personal favorite
similar to the election example that i
did today
and medstats 3 covers specific
statistical tests and regression
analysis similar to the vitamin d
example that i talked about today all
right so i'm now going to pass this back
to
jackie to answer any questions that you
might have
okay so a few questions kristin that
have come in we'll start with
um your um your slides regarding
the pulling data and the point
statistics
um a few questions here first why do a
million
simulations rather than calculate 65 000
probabilities of the purpose is to try
to replicate the methodology
uh yeah i so uh that's a great question
um i don't
actually know exactly how the miss
cannon center ran their calculation i
suspect that they did a simulation too
because i can tell sort of from the
histogram that they presented so that's
my guess
um that's the easiest way to calculate
probabilities in the computer is just to
run a big simulation
um then you don't have to think about
the map run it many times and you see
what happens and so actually writing out
those 65 000
different combinations going to be
harder than just flipping a virtual
point a million times so i tend to solve
a lot of probability problems actually
with a simulation that's my first
instinct
because it tends to be easier than doing
it mathematically
great question perfect so
um why does an error in predicting a win
in michigan increase the likelihood that
there is an error in predicting the win
for wisconsin
that's a great question so remember all
of these predictions are based on
polling data remember those
probabilities were basically just a
function of the polling data and
uh what happened in 2016 is that a lot
of the polls were off
and it wasn't like they were off
randomly they were all off in the same
direction um and so why would that occur
well
uh there's nothing you know sort of
isolated or special about the polling in
michigan
that's going to be different about the
polling in wisconsin
michigan and wisconsin also happen to be
states with very similar demographics
very similar similar electorates so if
the polling
that you know the people who are polling
in michigan uh get one answer it's
probably likely the people pulling in
wisconsin might even be some of the same
groups right that
administer these polls across different
states it's very likely that there's
errors in one you're going to be off by
kind of similar amounts in the other and
you saw this in the data i showed you
from the new york times
um they were really all off by very
similar amounts in the same direction
and that's just because whatever goes
wrong in michigan highly likely the same
thing is going to go wrong
and listen i mean i mentioned some of
the things you know if the pollsters
might be not reaching certain voters or
they may not be waiting in their models
uh the you know how who's likely to come
to the polls and things like this
okay so the next question is um are you
supposing that the probability of those
errors are uniformly distributed or are
you using some other distribution
that is such a great question so um
for the purposes of this little
illustration i wasn't too
fussed about how to model these but just
for fun because i'm curious about these
things i tried it both ways
and so um it depends on the range of
pulling errors that i allow
but basically i can get exactly the same
results if i choose uniform with a
certain range
as if i choose a t distribution uh with
a certain range now i
actually ended up in the ones i showed
you i use the t distribution
uh that's what 538.com says they use so
you know i sort of trying to mimic
theirs
um but actually just out of curiosity i
did it both ways and it doesn't make a
huge difference
as long as the uh the standard
deviations in the following year and the
range
uh end up being roughly the same from
those two distributions so yeah you can
do it both ways actually interestingly
enough
the second question here is how could
you um what could you do to account for
the potential residual compounding even
for those variables that you did
um include in the regression model
yeah so that is a great question this is
the problem with statistics
it's really hard to know when you're
wrong right you did one study
and just from that one study what tells
you that you're wrong
well a lot of times we actually don't
know um
so we have to always just keep in the
back of our minds when we're
interpreting results that there's the
possibility of residual confounding
um and there are some things that we can
do to try to get at it from a particular
study
um so one thing is people have done
simulations to show
that for example if you're modeling
something with a binary outcome
that usually uh residual confounding is
only going to cause
spurious associations that are so big
that is you're not going to get an odds
ratio of two
purely due to residual compound and
usually it's bounded in a simulation
somewhere between like an odd ratio of
0.6 and 1.6 so if you get
odds ratios that are much bigger outside
of that range it's unlikely that they're
entirely
uh explained by residual combining so
that's one thing some people have done
you know statisticians have done
modeling
simulations to try to get at like how
big of an effect how how much off could
you be
you're somewhat limited when it comes to
residual compounding not as much limited
when it comes to unmeasured compounding
your effect sizes are really small you
might say to the reader hey
you know these are within the range that
you might expect to see
the residual you can also do some
modeling yourself
for an individual study we often do what
are called sensitivity analyses
so you can try to to say well what if
there had been you know this much
measurement or that much measurement
error you can try to factor that in and
get a sense
um how much could residual confounding
be
in play here so people will sometimes do
that
another thing you can do is uh try to
have some kind of
a control analysis and i really like
this idea actually one of my favorite
studies to teach from is there was a
study that came out a number of years
ago
that was looking at big meat eating and
it found that people who ate red meat
had a higher mortality than people who
didn't eat so much red meat
um but one of the outcomes that they
looked at
was death by accidents and injuries
and they found just as much of an
increased risk of death from accidents
and injuries as they did
from cancer and heart disease and it's
very hard to come up with a plausible
causal story of how red meat moving
might increase your risk of like getting
shot by a gun or getting in a car exit
and so that actually serves as a nice
control
in that study because it shows you that
probably what you're picking up is
residual compounding people
eat a lot of red meat are riskier in
many other ways and so having nice
control analysis like that where there's
no plausible causal explanation
can also be a really good way to get at
that but you never know for sure right
these are all just ways of guessing that
so the next question is would
confounding be reduced by multivariate
analysis
yeah great question so what i showed you
in that vitamin d example
is they had done a multi-variable
analysis so they had done a regression
where they put a bunch of other
variables in the model in order to
adjust
for them and so this
trying to account for confounding i
think sometimes
we get um you know overly complacent
though and we think like oh we put
things in a statistical model we did our
multivariable model we adjusted for it
so we don't have to worry about
confounding anymore and it's not quite
that clean
as i said i think a lot of times um
we we feel overly confident after a
statistical adjustment whereas there
might still be
some either unmeasured or residual
confounding so it's not a panacea but
that
is one of the common techniques that we
use to at least try to start to get it
confounding yeah
okay and is there an easy and quick way
to spot these
statistical errors
oh that's a great question um and so
um use common sense so this is the thing
that i think
um even if you are not even if you're
not a statistician
a lot of these errors you can actually
spot just using common sense thinking
through the problem so for example the
physical activity in vitamin d
example i think if you think about have
vitamin d what are the things that cause
you that are big fitness
you don't need to know necessarily a ton
about statistics or realize that those
things are going to be linked and that
sounds a lot more plausible than like
you know the vitamin d changes your
phosphorus and your cells and that
somehow boosts your arabic activity so
just using
common sense is a really good uh a good
first principle a good place to start
another thing you can do
is look at figures uh pictures in your
in the paper
often there's things that you can see in
a picture that's kind of buried if they
just give you the results of a
statistical model so paying attention to
those pictures
making sure the pictures match the
actual model um
looking for red flags in a paper so i
did an earlier webinar on how to be a
statistical detective and i went through
some
some red flags you can look for in a
paper like things don't add up
you know sloppiness that might indicate
that the authors haven't thought through
things as carefully as they should have
um and so just you know kind of keeping
your your guard up
not trusting that just because the
author said they took care of it
that's the case being a little bit
skeptical interpreting things with your
skeptical hat on
and that's what a lot of in my teaching
i try to get my students to do is just
use common sense and be skeptical and
don't think that the authors are more of
an authority than you you you
have using your your common sense can uh
can spot a lot of these
potential issues and so follow up
question of that is
um how can people practice um spotting
statistical errors in
in papers or in the media do you have
any strategies or
tools that they can use uh sure so i'll
refer you to the
webinar i did on how to be a statistical
detective there were some very specific
skills i went through there
uh that could um that were easy to use
that could you could use to spot errors
and papers and
i just spent a lot of time doing that um
if you're a researcher
you have the opportunity to review
papers especially if you're a young
researcher say yes to those
opportunities to review papers
because in going through other papers um
it's a really good practice when you're
kind of scrutinizing them carefully
to look for these kinds of red flags um
and you know it
this is the kind of thing you develop
with experience uh
if you have your skeptical hat on there
to start
um and um you know you learn a few
statistical principles
um take courses and statistics and then
you can
be a statistical detective and
you can kind of go into papers with that
skeptical view if you're reading the
news
and you have the opportunity to go and
pull the original paper and look
carefully at that original paper that's
often a good way to scrutinize things
from the news
let's go back to the original paper and
see did that does it really show that
and if we can't control all the
confounding variables then a large part
of the studies are actually inaccurate
and we have no way to know answers to
many questions
is that correct uh yeah so
yes i mean you know we you have to be
careful with observation
phase you have to keep in the back of
your mind that confounding could be an
issue
you want to read those studies carefully
how well did they adjust for competitive
they
take into account major things like
physical activity in this particular
design
um and of course all of science is an
accumulation of evidence so we never
just want to look at one study and say
well this study found
that vitamin d improves dementia and
therefore the
we need to look across many studies
across replication
to really become confident in a lot of
these associations and things like
vitamin d we're hoping
you know that eventually somebody does a
randomized trial and we might get a
better answer
from a randomized trial
perfect okay and um
last question um actually had to do with
your last response is if there had been
a systematic review done
on vitamin d and vo2
causal relationships that adjust for
vitamin d intake and physical activity
right so i mean systematic reviews
meta-analyses are great because they try
to pool the evidence across a lot of
different studies
and so you're hoping that by doing that
you're
um you know you're getting a better
estimate of the effect you have to be a
little careful though because if all of
the studies done
were observational studies and you're
pooling all these observational studies
it could be that there's systematic
error right the
same error that affects one study might
affect another study
so in doing a review like that if you
really wanted to look at vitamin d and
aerobic fitness
hopefully you'd be very careful to only
include studies where they have
carefully accounted for physical
activity for example
um so you have to keep in mind all these
same biases might be present in many
studies
so a meta-analysis or systematic for you
could simply replicate
the the systematic error across many
studies um so that's where being careful
about what studies you include in your
review can be very helpful
perfect okay well i think that's all of
the questions that we have time for
today thank you so much kristen this was
a great webinar i'm very informative
we just want to let everyone know
that kristin's medical statistics
program is available on stanford
online you'll see a button on your
screen there if you would like to learn
more about this program
um and enroll it will take you to the
program page to learn more
um thank you again kristin for the
really informative webinar
thanks jackie thanks everyone